it's Memorial Day the unofficial kickoff  to summer and even though the holiday  may be different this year with social  distancing during the pandemic we're  still going to have a lot of fun before  we get to that we of course want to  remember and give thanks to the brave  men and women who made the ultimate  sacrifice fighting for our country and  freedom we'd also like to honor the  heroes on the frontlines battling the  coronavirus the countless doctors nurses  EMTs police officers and other first  responders putting themselves in harm's  way thank you for everything you're  doing to help Americans get through this